Kent Beck and Martin Fowler popularized the notion of refactoring as part of
extreme programming in the 1990s. The idea was to move some design activities
that were previously done before implementation was started into the actual
implementation phase of development. The intent was to reduce rework in
situations with rapidly changing requirements. The first step in refactoring is
the recognition of bad smells, which are code situations that are suggestive of
design problems, such as duplicate code, too many comments, or long classes. So
you can think, bad smells as being, things to avoid in other words,
design principles describing situations which you, you don't want to be in.
The Fowler's book recognizes dozens of bad smells and the avoidance of each
should be, could be thought of as a design principle. For example, the duplicate
code bad smell should be thought of as the avoid duplicate code by factoring
principle. You're encouraged to explore Fowler's book as a way of becoming
familiar with these situations, it is referenced in the class resources page.